Andrew Tate's alleged victims to have
him locked up right now with this
ongoing case have been exposed by a
woman that was also there and made some
very good points in this video about
this why on Earth are they taking his
cars I don't know what maybe this video
will shed some light on it I only saw
the headline on it and I didn't read it
but what what does what could that part
like what could justify taking all their
cars I don't understand right normally
if they're confiscating property in for
evidence I'm a lay person so uh I would
think there would have been a crime
committed inside the vehicle and they
need it and they need it for forensic
evidence but they haven't even they
still haven't found proof so it's like
what do you what do the cars have
anything to do with anything right only
if he's saying I've never met this woman
I've never had anything to do with her
I've never had any interaction and then
they go there and they find the woman's
DNA in there like I don't know I I I
don't know seems like a whole lot of BS
situation first of all I would like to
start by saying that there are no in
this case don't start today pre-list
here in 2022 when two girls that lived
in my home with me lock themselves in
their room and claimed to Beholder but
here's the fact
when the authorities and the police
broke into their room raided our homes
they forgot to mention something really
important and that's that the key was in
their room on their bed now
I don't think it's just the victims
lying anymore it's the police as well
there is a reason why they don't want to
put that certain detail in the files and
it's pretty obvious this is all about
some election in 2024 and the vacuum
spot for the decode leadership that the
prosecutor wants the police know there
was no crime and they are holding the
Tate Brothers locked with no evidence
because they think it's good for
Romanian politics now the other two
victims that the police claim to be
involved in this case are me and
batteries and we have been given three
statements so far clearly saying we are
it's funny how the People speaking like
the girls they know speaking for them
mean nothing but the random girl
speaking against them means so much like
why don't we take these into account
with anything why isn't it equally as
important am I missing something
corruption just goes so deep in in in in
all politics in every country and
anybody who thinks that their politician
is straight is sadly just delusional I
have no idea about Romanian politics
ticks but I would imagine they have you
know it's a smaller country and they
probably have less visibility into the
process so you saw They just added 30
days to their no it's true they're
locked up too I thought Tristan was out
Tristan's into yeah no sneak a
millionaire party anytime soon that's
all right well
it'll happen it'll happen it'll be even
cooler delayed gratification why they
don't believe I see I saw what I thought
to be false accusations and uh absolute
corruption political corruption in the
Brett Kavanaugh hearings when they were
helding the hearings to decide whether
or not he would be appointed to the
Supreme Court of the United States they
pulled out this woman named Christine
blasey Ford from his early high school
years he was early High School who said
that at a party that she couldn't say
where it was she couldn't say when it
was she couldn't remember who was there
but she remembered that you know they
had a couple drinks and there was beer
and Brett Kavanaugh tried to get into
her swimsuit in a in a bedroom and she
came and this woman was so that say she
was about 13 or 14 at the time of it
happening this woman was uh in her
probably she looked like she was in her
early 50s so we're talking about 40-year
difference with no memory no details no
nothing and something that may or may
not have happened and the public made it
out to be like he was a serial rapist
who dragged women into the you know back
alleys and beat them and rape them and
this was all political because he was a
conservative he would have been a
conservative Supreme Court Justice and
he was being appointed by President
Trump and he just needed to be confirmed
by the Congress and they and this woman
had no credibility her story had so many
holes in it the poor guy had this look
on his face of complete sheer
exasperation and I can tell you my gut I
looked at this guy and I was like I know
what a guy looks like and that ain't it
this guy's a dork this guy has done
nothing isn't it crazy his whole life
and that and they tried so hard to
destroy him and it was in the spotlight
in American Media that our politicians
were trying to destroy somebody with
allegations that were not true there's
no way they were true it happens
everywhere so I'm not after seeing that
this doesn't surprise me at all and if
this guy this prosecutor whoever or
whoever she mentioned that's trying to
get a political office is trying to
Garner support of left-wing activists in
in in Romania for his campaign these
idiots who walk around and act like
women don't have rights and we're
second-class citizens which just is not
true this is a great way to do it take
down a misogynist
isn't it crazy how much they throw
around the word racist at this point to
where it's almost becoming like racist
where it just doesn't even mean as much
and it's really sad it's it's like if
it's a horrible [__] crime and
they're making it nothing yeah yeah it
is sad and crazy and stupid and racism
is a horrible a horrible thing too and
they've taken that and watered it down
so that it means almost nothing like
I'll call me a racist or whatever yeah
I'm sure that used to be like a real
that used to be a real insult with like
proof now it legit means Jack [__] are
not victims and we have never worked
with or for Andrew and Tristan Tate in
any way but our statements keep getting
thrown away the police don't care about
the truth they don't listen to neither
me nor batteries instead they choose to
listen to two girls that went on a
luxurious vacation on the French Riviera
a week or so after being rescued for
whatever they claimed to be another fact
is that the police threw away the
surveillance footage from the house
inside the house and outside the house
because they don't don't consider it
evidence evidence that proves that those
girls were able and were going for walks
they were going out of the house with
their phones whenever they wanted
wherever they wanted we want Justice
they want political points and I'm sure
that my
statements will never be put in the Case
Files
iterating your point that this these
women are not being listened to and I'm
sorry because I got off track with a
Christine blasey Ford thing but yes the
media gave all kinds of credibility and
attention to This Woman's shoddy
accusation shoddy look it up for
yourself don't take my word for it it
was much a horseshit and they they gave
no attention to people who were there as
character Witnesses none none so again
it all boils down to the media
manipulation and that's what this is and
the more you know you hear more stories
like this this girl is Lovely by the way
just she's bad the truth all they want
is political points the corruption is so
highly valued
Justice will never come out to the
surface okay the thing is with this all
right let's see the details yeah no I
want to watch the rest of it cases in
general when women speak out about men
and then have found not guilty off
that's their um assistant's coat
Tristan's coat is exquisite just have to
say they should be like I wish they were
fashion people commentating on them all
the time just just strictly strictly on
their fashion Tristan is the damage he's
done something fashion God as far as I'm
concerned well you want to listen but
you're talking about men and then I
found not guilty after is the damage is
done some people no matter what are
still gonna think things of Andrew Tate
of course these fans and people know the
truth I'm gonna understand it was
corrupt but it should be some sort of
compensation in place once he's found
not guilty in this case still no
evidence and they're just locking him up
for nothing and ignoring the people that
say good 10 seconds left she's not
saying nothing you want to like
subscribe follow the video of yourself
[Music]
won't last long yeah the feelings